[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the 20th century modern man
moving quickly about his business
moving forward in a world of progress a
world
so filled with today's transactions man
seldom finds time to look back
until something extraordinary happens
and he has no choice
[Music]
if this prehistoric monster appeared in
the mainstream of traffic in any 20th
century city
modern man would forget today's progress
even if just for long enough to get out
of the way
he'd be reduced to the single basic
drive every man has inherited from his
ancestors
the instinct of self-preservation the
chances of meeting a dinosaur in today's
world are very slim
but the possibility of contacting
another kind of prehistoric monster is
all too real
this monster is venereal disease
this is an enlarged reproduction of the
germ known as gonococcus
the germ of gonorrhea a disease known
five thousand years ago to the chinese
and to the ancient arabs greeks hindus
and romans
still known today in the modern world of
the 20th century
these are spirochete germs shaped like
corkscrews
syphilis germs first referred to in
european writings of the 15th century
syphilis has kept pace with a changing
world for 400 years
promiscuity and ignorance of the causes
and consequences of the venereal
diseases have contributed to their
spread
there is evidence that many young people
do not know that gonorrhea and syphilis
are different diseases
that they can be caught only by sexual
relations and not just with an
infected person of the opposite sex but
also by homosexual practices
down through the years much has been
learned about gonorrhea and syphilis
modern medicine has developed drugs
providing our present generation with
effective cures
until today here and now these diseases
have found a new ally
complacency modern society has lost its
fear to the point of carelessness
and the monster venereal disease
continues as a modern heritage
[Music]
this young man for instance is a carrier
that means he is carrying in his body
the germs of gonorrhea
he knows something is wrong but still
hasn't worked up the courage to talk to
anyone about it
the previous weekend john's family went
to the cottage
on saturday night john and his buddy
invited their girlfriends to the house
for a few drinks
[Music]
john has been going steady with linda
for six months now
he thinks more of her than any girl he
has gone with before
and linda feels the same way about john
for the last three days john has been
feeling a painful burning sensation each
time he is urinated
and now this morning there was a new
problem john had seen a discharge
down there and he knew it was pus now he
was scared
what to do there's only one thing to do
and john's friend
urges him to do it and now see his
family doctor
and as soon as possible he's the only
person who can give the right kind of
[Music]
advice
well john the microscopic examination
confirms
that the burning sensation you've been
feeling when you urinate
and also the discharge of hostages i saw
this morning
are symptoms of gonorrhea one of the
venereal diseases
how gonorrhea can have very serious
consequences in an adult male as time
goes on
if he does not receive the proper
treatment
you see the gonorrhea germs enter a
man's body at the head of the penis
they travel up and invade the lining of
the urinary canal
inflammation results and this is what
causes the burning sensation during
urination
it also causes the discharge of pus from
the penis
these are symptoms of gonorrhea in the
acute stage when it is very infectious
and of course anyone having such
symptoms should abstain from
all sexual relations i feel all right
doctor
if i were infected wouldn't the
infection make me sick
well if you mean nauseated or headachy
when you use the word sick the answer is
no
but gonorrhea can cause complications
that can
completely disable a person john and
these complications
can arise if you neglect proper
treatment
you see the gonorrhea germs may extend
deeper to involve the posterior part of
the urinary canal
the prostate gland and sperm canal
the infection may cause an abscess of
the prostate land
and inflammation of the spermatic core
how this can result in sterility
in a male and arthritis also can result
from
a neglected gonorrhea infection
so you see john if proper treatment
isn't given as quickly as possible
the subsequent complications can become
life sentences for a man
for example he may never be a father
unfortunately this disease can be cured
with modern drugs
but tissues that are scarred
and damaged from these complications can
never be repaired
all the time we've been talking in fact
ever since i first knew something was
wrong
i've been trying to figure out where i
might have got this infection
i've used the toilet in public
restaurants during the last two weeks
but they look clean maybe the dishes
weren't sterilized or
no hold on a minute john you can stop
all your figuring there is only
one way that you could have contacted
gonorrhea
and that is through sexual intercourse
with an infected person
now there is no immunity to the disease
john
a person can contract vd any number of
times
and furthermore no reliance can be
placed on
contraceptives as a means of preventing
infection
all this business about dirty dishes and
unclean washrooms i'm afraid is just a
lot of nonsense
this is very important john it means
that there is an infected girl who must
be found
and treated before her own health can be
dangerously affected
or before she passes the disease onto
somebody else
now i would like you to tell me who the
girl or
girls are with whom you may have had
relations during the past two weeks
and how they can be located
the health department will assist us in
this
it will be done with courtesy and in the
strictest confidence girl will not even
be told who gave her name
uh well there was only one girl
but it couldn't have been her doctor
we've been going steady for several
months
well you must have been infected by her
if she's the only one
she should be examined and treated
immediately so
please try to understand how very
important this is for her
now are you being truthful when you say
there were no contacts
yes she was the only one
[Music]
besides you must be wrong i just don't
believe she would have stayed with me
knowing that i would get an infection
well that's the sad part of this whole
thing john
that she is infected herself and
naturally she wouldn't know she's passed
along the infection to you
see gonorrhea is not as easily detected
in women as it is in men
it may cause fewer symptoms
but surely you can realize that you'll
be actually doing her a favor by seeing
to it that she has the benefit of
medical examination
sure i can see your point doctor but i
just can't
believe it
[Music]
well whether you believe it or not isn't
important john but we must know
who she is let me think about it for a
while doctor
i'll come back after i've had a chance
to do some thinking
well while you're taking your time john
just keep one thing in mind will you
time is that girl's enemy right now and
your silence could [ __ ] her
now i know that you think you're being
honorable and withholding your name
but your mistaken sense of honor could
easily
lead to serious illness
she has passed gonorrhea onto you john
but if she has been promiscuous with
other men she may also be carrying the
germs of syphilis in her body
now syphilis is even more devastating
than gonorrhea
if it isn't properly treated
do you want to be an accomplice to this
by keeping your secret
when you're in a position to help
all right doctor
[Music]
it's linda miller she works as a
secretary for one of the manufacturing
plants in town
i know you don't think so now john but i
know that you'll be glad you told me
you ask why we've called you here why we
think that you may have a venereal
disease isn't important linda
the important thing is that you see your
doctor without delay
he'll examine you and have some
laboratory tests done
if you are infected immediate treatment
is terribly important
wherever you're getting your information
ms johnson all i can say to you is that
you've got the wrong girl
now if you'll excuse me i'd like to be
getting along linda
let me explain some of the simple facts
about venereal disease too
hear me out and if you still want to
leave you're quite free to go
gonorrhea in women or girls may cause
very few symptoms
when symptoms do occur usually they take
the form of a
burning sensation during urination or
there may be a vaginal discharge
now even when these symptoms do occur
they're often ignored
they may even disappear in a short time
but the gonorrhea and germs do not
disappear
they must apply and they travel now if
early treatment is not given
the infection can spread to the uterus
and from there to the fallopian tubes
information in the fallopian tubes can
cause serious illness
the scarring which results may cause
sterility
sterility linda a small word with a
world meaning
do you know what that could mean to a
girl no babies
instead of the joy of a family of her
own the memory of an illness which
could have been completely prevented
now as i said before linda you're you're
perfectly free to go
i'd like you to stay we can discuss this
problem
this is a problem linda a very serious
one
and only you can solve it for yourself
won't you stay
all right miss johnson i'll stay but i
don't see how this problem applies to me
i feel all right in fact i have trouble
keeping my weight down
i have such a good appetite if i do have
this
thing wouldn't i know it perhaps the
worst aspect of the venereal diseases is
that the
early signs and symptoms may be
overlooked
or passed off as some other illness now
i've already mentioned that
gonorrhea may cause few or very mild
symptoms in women
it can be detected only by medical
examination
and laboratory tests and cured only by
proper treatment from your physician
now the first stage of syphilis in a
woman may show itself by a
shanker or sore forming on the outside
genital area
but often the shanker forms internally
now it's typically small and painless
now because it is painless
and usually hidden syphilis often goes
undetected
until it's reached an advanced stage now
even in the later stages syphilis may
show itself by symptoms that are
mistaken for other temporary minor
skin rash and swollen glands may appear
six to eight weeks after the shank has
cleared up
a sore throat and fever may occur small
sores may appear around the mouth
and patches of hair may fall out now
any one or all of these symptoms may
occur
often their true nature isn't realized
because they're so common to other
humans
unfortunately often syphilis is not
diagnosed until it's
caused permanent damage to the heart or
nervous system
but if the infection is noticed soon
enough isn't there some kind of medicine
that a person could buy at a drugstore
to clear it out
[Music]
linda there isn't any kind of medicine
that can be bought over a counter which
can cure a venereal disease
one must rely on proper drugs prescribed
by a doctor
now any person who's foolish enough to
believe that a bottle of pills or
or a tube of ointment in a plain wrapper
might be effective in the treatment or
cure of venereal disease
it's going to be very sorry later in
life i don't remember that shanker you
described
and i certainly remember that burning
feeling if i'd ever had it
in fact i don't think of any of the
symptoms at all so how can you be so
sure i have an infection i'm not sure
linda
in fact i i sincerely hope you're right
but the only way we can know either of
us for sure
is for you to be examined by your own
doctor
look think about it this way for a
moment
in a few years time you'll very likely
be getting married
now if a woman with untreated syphilis
becomes pregnant
she could pass this disease on to her
unborn child
now that means that it's possible that
the baby could be born
dead or deformed now before your wedding
your doctor will advise a blood test
if you are infected wouldn't you rather
find out about it now
get the proper treatment and be cured
instead of waiting until two or three
days before your wedding date
millennial disease does not go away by
ignoring it linda
please don't wait any longer
and then if you are infected the doctor
will ask you for the name of the person
who gave you the disease
now please cooperate so that the prophet
is the devs
what does that mean and anyway how would
i know how i got the disease even if i
was infected
or where these germs must be everywhere
i could have picked it up from a toilet
seat someplace
linda it just doesn't happen that way
venereal disease is transmitted from one
adult to another through intimate sexual
contact
now look and i'm not stressing this
because i i want to pry into your
private life
but if you are infected i'm asking you
to tell a doctor in private
the name of the person who passed the
nereal disease to you
he may have infected others and they'll
in fact steal others
it's your serious responsibility to
protect the health of other people as
well as your own
now you can do this by giving the doctor
the information he
asks for so that all contacts can be
located and
like you be given the benefit of an
examination
and treatment if necessary and what
happens after i tell the doctor who it
is
the doctor may contact him or he may
obtain the help of trained health
department people to follow up the case
either way taft and discretion are used
to avoid any embarrassment
i don't see how that could be done in my
case
last month i had my first experience
with a man quite a lot older than i am
it only happened once i didn't know it
could lead to this
he was staying at the summer resort
where i was spending my holidays
i know his name but i don't know where
he lives
i don't think he comes from this part of
the country at all
all you can do is give his name in the
name of the summer resort to the doctor
linda
he'll take it from there now
let's make an appointment to your family
doctor
[Music]
donald ferguson this is linda miller
hello linda come in
[Music]
won't you sit down
doctor miss johnson the public health
nurse
told me it's possible that i might have
an infection that's what i came to see
you about
these two young people by a chain of
circumstances
contracted venereal disease but
fortunately their infection was detected
early enough and treatment began in time
to cure it
before serious consequences could result
but one of the man quite a lot older
than linda
will he be so fortunate linda's doctor
and public health personnel will do
everything possible to find him and
treat him
but how many others will become infected
before the chain of infection is broken
venereal diseases are no respecters of
persons
the health of thousands of our people is
threatened by the increase in the
incidence of venereal diseases
the medical profession and public health
departments are concerned
by the widespread occurrence of
infectious syphilis and gonorrhea
public clinics provide free treatment in
most communities
but they can't help without your
cooperation
venereal disease can affect people of
any age
not even the unborn baby is safe
from the body destroying menace of
venereal disease
ignorance apathy relaxation of moral
standards
are its allies linda discovered this
the difficult way by experience
education and a constant awareness
of the danger of promiscuous sexual
behavior
must become a part of our daily life
this is the 20th century but how many of
us in our modern age are still in a
prehistoric stage in our thinking about
venereal disease
[Applause]
why has venereal disease continued as a
blight on society down through the ages
when it should be as extinct as this
dinosaur in this day of scientific model
how long will it take society to develop
a social conscience as advanced as the
material gains we now enjoy
can syphilis and gonorrhea be eradicated
before we defeat complacency and
ignorance
can our generation govern its own
behaviors efficiently to abolish the
menace of venereal disease for future
[Music]
generations
[Music]
you